on sonne déjà c'est le téléphone c'est
un fiancé qui vous demande ah merci
Marie-Hélène
je m'appelle Marie-Hélène Cardet j'ai 17
ans je suis fermière normande je suis
Marie-Hélène Gardet j'ai 76 ans je suis
normande et je suis devenue religieuse
[Musique]
j'ai 12 vaches qui sont normandes j'ai
deux frères et une sœur qui sont
normants et aussi
et puis qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
maintenant que vous êtes la meilleure
ménagée rurale c'est difficile de
devenir aménager ruraux
il faut savoir faire de
ce concours c'était organisé par toutes
les écoles ménagères de France donc on
avait concouru d'abord au niveau de
l'école après au niveau de la région et
enfin les premières de départements
étaient
[Musique]
rassemblés à Paris ici c'était les
différentes épreuves qu'on a eu à faire
c'était une chemise de nuit
et on avait le soir le résultat à
l'hôtel de ville de Paris donc on était
tout habillés en costume régional et
tout d'un coup j'ai entendu mon nom je
revenais pas mais bon voilà c'était la
première fois à Paris et moi ce que je
me souviens surtout
c'est que j'avais été accueilli on était
parti la veille j'étais accueillie chez
les Soeurs de Saint-Sauveur qui était
là-bas à Paris et là-bas il y avait une
fille c'est un foyer de jeune fille et
elle jouait du piano moi je n'avais
jamais vu quelqu'un jouer au piano c'est
le souvenir vraiment que je me souviens
le plus on était 72 paraît-il et il y en
a une qui pour les 50 ans a eu l'idée de
d'essayer de retrouver tout le monde il
s'est créé des liens très très vite et
puis voilà on a formé comme une nouvelle
famille la bonne petite ménagère que
voilà mais dites donc vous êtes prêtes à
avoir un mari influencé maintenant
c'est vrai pas encore mais il va venir
vite voyez on sonne déjà c'est le
téléphone c'est un fiancé qui vous
demande oh merci Marie-Hélène
ah là là là là là ça fait drôle de
s'entendre après tant d'années je pense
surtout que ce que ça représente les
bons moments dans ces années là maman je
me souviens elle allait
papa avait planté un petit champ de
pomme sur de panna couteau elle allait
les vendre pour elle la vie elle était
difficile elle était restée sur une
petite ferme avec
et puis voilà quoi j'ai senti ça en moi
je le portais en moi déjà et puis j'ai
décidé de d'entrer au courant les
premières années j'enseignais des
enfants qui avaient un peu des
difficultés en 74 je suis parti au Congo
je fais 12 ans il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants polio on a beaucoup travaillé
en lien avec des médecins hollandais qui
venaient pour repérer les enfants qui
avaient des séquelles enfin voilà les
membres paralysés puis on faisait la
couture avec les femmes alphabétisation
ça fait 33 ans que je suis à Barfleur
j'ai travaillé d'abord sur la paroisse
après
j'étais aumônier à la prison de
Cherbourg pendant une douzaine d'années
maintenant je vais avec les familles du
voyage et les forains
qu'on va aller faire un petit tour sur
le quai Barfleur qui est classé parmi
l'un des plus beaux villages de France
on s'en lâche pas on y est toujours bien
je me lève de bonheur et je vais voir le
lever du soleil ah c'est superbe c'est
superbe
[Musique]
j'aime bien être là
je pense que j'ai
j'étais heureuse en 63 même s'il y avait
des moments difficiles des situations de
famille difficiles
et puis je pense avoir été heureux toute
ma vie
[Musique]